[música]
Olá pessoal, tudo bem com vocês? Que
alegria!
Iniciando
agora hoje os nossos encontros de
direito civil com a nossa mega revisão
de direito civil para o nosso exame de
ordem. A gente sempre acerta todas as
questões com a nossa, esses encontros,
né, que é a Roberta Queirose e as seis
questões distribuído em sete encontros
que correspondem à sete partes do
direito civil, do Código Civil, muito
especificamente hoje sobre sucessões. E
eu quero mandar um beijo muito carinhoso
pra galera que tá aí ao vivo
acompanhando a gente hoje e que já se
manifestou até no chat. Tá? Um beijo
para vocês, sejam muito bem-vindos e
muito bem-vindas a esse encontro
especial que hoje inaugura esses sete
momentos diferentes do direito civil. E
meus amores, vamos iniciar hoje com a
parte de sucessões,
muito categoria. Manda o link para todo
mundo aí que precisar assistir essa
aula, os seus amigos e suas amigas que
precisam estudar um pouquinho pra parte
de direito civil. E eh eu gosto de ficar
de trás para frente, né, no direito
civil, justamente porque a gente começa
pela parte mais pesada, que em alguns
momentos é muito cobrado em prova, eh em
algumas partes específicas, como cálculo
de partilha, e aí a gente acaba
trabalhando essas partes aqui nesses
encontros, tá bom? Então, beijo para
vocês. Vamos iniciar o nosso direito
civil, parte de sucessões e a gente vai
fazer os desenhos categoria que você não
vai acreditar no final desses encontros
que você tem desenhos maravilhosos para
lembrar e recordar essa matéria. Então,
vamos pro nosso material. Sem maiores
delongas, aliás, para quem não me
conhece, eu sou a professora Roberta
Queirosa aqui do Gran OAB, leciono
direito civil aqui no GR e processo
civil para concurso, mas aqui na OAB,
direito civil. E um detalhe importante
do coração, tô aqui no canal Direito,
como nunca se viu aqui no YouTube também
e lá no Instagram @robertakeiroz, onde
você pode acompanhar algumas coisas da
minha vida, né? Porque o Instagram eu só
posto coisas da minha vida mesmo. Mas
vamos lá então. Vamos. Obrigada, viu?
Elvis, Bianca, André, Alícia, que tá
sempre comigo. Um beijo enorme,
Fabrício, Amanda, Lu, um beijo enorme
para vocês. Vamos lá, então, de olho no
nosso material e nós vamos conversar
agora sobre sucessões. Vamos fazer
nossos desenhos do coração. Deixa eu
pegar minha caneta aqui pra gente
começar os nossos desenhos e vamos
embora. Olha só,
seguindo aqui o bonde,
eh,
se a gente tá falando de sucessão, é
porque alguém morreu e deixou bens, né?
É basicamente isso. Então, que que a
gente tem aqui?
Aliás, sabe o que que eu vou fazer?
Eu vou pegar, eu vou dividir esse
material. Pera aí que eu vou arrumar
aqui. Eu vou dividir esse material
porque no último dia, na nossa revisão
de véspera, eu vou entregar esse
material lindo, lindo, lindo.
Só para quem estiver
com a gente.
Real oficial.
Vou colocar aqui
dividido.
Eu vou montar um caderno. Olha como eu
sou. Olha como eu sou uma pessoa boa. Eu
vou montar um caderno
e vou entregar esse caderno
só para quem
estiver com a gente.
que é sério, real, oficial. Por lá na
frente
não tem, né, gente? Eu tô tentando mexer
aqui e como a professora é um pouquinho
lerda,
né? Como a pessoa é um pouquinho lerda,
tenha calma aí. Eu vou preparar esse
material bem lindo, lindo
para vocês. Bem lindo, lindo mesmo.
Porque aí
nós vamos ter, sabe o quê? Um caderno.
Tive essa ideia agora. E é sobre isso.
E é sobre isso que nós vamos
fazer. Nós vamos ter um caderno
lindo, lindo, lindo
da nossa matéria
de todas as matérias
de direito civil. E é sobre, olha que
coisa mais linda que eu vou fazer para
você. cada parte dividido bonitinho. Dá
uma olhada aqui. Vou mostrar agora. KQ
nornebista. Então vamos lá. Aqui hoje a
gente começa a parte de sucessões. Eu
coloquei essa imagem bem bonita aí para
representar, né, um pouquinho da
família, um pouquinho da saudade que a
gente eh encontra quando a gente fala de
sucessões, que é uma das partes do
direito civil mais envolvidas aí na nas
relações familiares, né?
E quando a gente fala de sucessão,
a gente tá falando categoricamente da
morte de alguém, tá? Da morte de alguém.
E ocorrendo a morte surge um fenômeno
chamado herança.
E dessa herança a gente entrega os bens
aos herdeiros.
E a gente entrega esses bens aos
herdeiros fazendo uma partilha de bens
num inventário ou judicial ou
extrajudicial. Então, a gente tá falando
disso. E quando a gente faz essa
partilha, a gente segue basicamente
regras de partilha, professora. Então, a
gente tá estudando as regras de
partilha. Exatamente. Então, a gente
pega a herança que foi deixada,
entrega aos herdeiros,
seguindo regras de partilha.
Mas você precisa lembrar
que quando a gente fala de herança,
basicamente
ocorrida a morte de uma pessoa,
essa pessoa deixa vários bens.
Imagina que ela tenha deixado
bens, imóveis.
Imagina que ela tenha deixado dinheiro.
Imagina que ela tenha deixado
bens móveis.
Tá vendo? Várias coisinhas aqui, né?
A pessoa morreu, ela deixa as coisas
dela.
Quando ocorre efetivamente a morte, sabe
o que que a gente faz? A gente pega
todos esses bens aqui
e coloca dentro de uma sacola,
né, imaginária aqui de Papai Noel, essa
sacolona aqui imaginária.
E simplesmente
entrega aos herdeiros de maneira
fictícia. Presta atenção agora. a gente
entrega de maneira fiícia, porque os
herdeiros eles vão ficar aqui, ó,
segurando
a herança
de maneira
virtual.
Tá vendo?
Cada herdeiro fica aqui, ó, tomando
conta de um pedacinho da herança. Vamos
colocar uma cor nos herdeiros, só para
você entender como é que funciona isso.
Vamos fingir que esse herdeiro aqui é o
herdeiro laranja. Tá vendo a carinha
dele laranja aqui? O outro herdeiro é o
herdeiro,
vamos botar azul.
E o outro herdeiro é o herdeiro roxo.
Tá vendo?
Quando você visualiza isso, você vai
compreender
que esses herdeiros, eles são
proprietários, na verdade não de bem
específico.
Eles são proprietários de uma cota
parte.
De uma cota parte. Ou seja, se nós temos
aqui três herdeiros, cada herdeiro desse
é dono não de um bem específico, mas de
uma cota. Eu tenho a cota do roxo, tá
vendo aqui? Olha lá a cota do roxo. Eu
tenho a cota do azul.
A cota do azul. E eu tenho a cota do
laranja.
Tá vendo? Eu não tenho um herdeiro
proprietário de um bem específico.
Professor, e como que isso pode cair na
minha prova? Primeiro, você vai observar
que a herança
é, na verdade, um conjunto de bens,
é um conjunto
de bens,
tá? E é um conjunto de bens que é
considerado imóvel.
Botar aqui assim, ó. É um conjunto de
bens que é considerado
imóvel por disposição legal. Então, as
regras de imóvel a gente aplica aqui.
É uma universalidade,
é uma universalidade
de bens, claro e evidente, porque é um
conjunto patrimonial. E é até que seja
feita a partilha
indivível.
Então, olha que interessante, é um
conjunto de bens,
como a gente tem a síndrome cadernal,
né, como diz o professor Pablo, a gente
faz tudo bem bonitinho para ficar
bonitinho para você no seu material. É
um conjunto de bens, aliás, não gostei
disso, vou colocar assim, ó. é um
conjunto de bens
caracterizado por ser imóvel por
disposição legal. É uma universalidade e
é indivisível até que seja feita a
partilha de bens.
E aí, gente, olha que interessante. A
gente pintou aqui os herdeiros, eles
entram nessa posse desde a morte pelo
chamado princípio
da Saizine, lembra? lá do 1784,
ocorrida a morte, entra-se imediatamente
na posse propriedade dos bens aos
herdeiros. E aí o que que acontece? Isso
é uma ficção.
E como cada herdeiro é dono de uma cota,
a gente vai fazer uma anotação aqui para
você não esquecer uma regra básica que
cai em prova. Se o examinador perguntar
para você assim: "Ah, o herdeiro,
o herdeiro pode vender um bem específico
da da herança, por exemplo, imagina que
eu tenha três herdeiros. Três herdeiros
e o morto deixou três casas,
três herdeiros, três casas. Eu posso
presumir que cada casa é de um herdeiro?
Não, não posso presumir isso. Porque, na
verdade, enquanto não ocorre a partilha,
nenhum herdeiro é dono de um bem
específico da herança. Hum, hum. Nenhum
herdeiro é dono de um bem específico. Os
herdeiros são donos de uma cota. Então,
o herdeiro não pode vender um bem
específico da herança, tá? Não pode.
Então, olha lá, a gente vai anotar aqui,
ó. O herdeiro, o herdeiro
ele tem direito a uma cota. Nesse
exemplo que a gente deu aqui é 1/3 para
cada um. Então, 1/3 pro laranja, 1/3 pro
azul, 1/3 pro roxo. De modo que se ele é
dono apenas de uma cota, a gente tem a
regra do coração número um. Ele não
pode
alienar
bem
específico.
Claro que não, porque ele não é dono de
um bem específico.
O que ele pode fazer
é
alienar e aí é ceder
a sua cota. Ele pode ceder a sua
cota. Então, o herdeiro roxo, ele pode
ceder a cota dele para alguém? Pode. Aí
aqui a gente tem uma regra bem bacana.
Professora, como assim? Ele pode alienar
a cota dele? Pode, ele pode. Aí aqui a
gente tem uma regra bem interessante.
Que regra é essa? Curte só isso aqui.
Olha só.
Se ele quer alienar é porque ele quer
ceder.
Ele pode ceder de duas formas, de forma
gratuita,
que é como se fosse uma doação, né?
Então, a gente coloca aqui que ele
estaria
doando de forma gratuita. Ele pode doar
de forma onerosa,
seria uma venda.
Por exemplo, possivelmente a minha cota
vale 15 milhão. Você dê para alguém por
500.000
para eu receber o dinheiro mais rápido.
Pode acontecer, né? Muito cuidado. Se
você tem a possibilidade de doar,
basicamente você pode doar para quem
você quiser.
Quem você quiser, porque você não tá
cobrando nada em troca. Então você pode
doar para quem você quiser. Agora para
vender, você tem que seguir
obrigatoriamente a regra do 1794.
Muito cuidado com essa regra, por se
você quiser vender,
imagina que o herdeiro roxo aqui, ele
quer vender a cota dele. Ele tem que dar
o direito de
preência
para os outros herdeiros, porque se é
venda não faz diferença quem tá
comprando. Então eu tenho que dar a
preferência aos outros herdeiros,
Roberta,
de modo que se ele aliena e não dá a
preferência a outro herdeiro, esse
herdeiro que tiver interessado, ele pode
pagar o valor que foi pago em até 180
dias, ou seja, ele tem 180 dias contados
da sessão para observar
o a preferência entre os herdeiros no
sentido de tomar para si, ou seja, de
adjudicar.
Então, se vamos escrever direito, né,
profe? Se ele, o roxo, quer alienar a
cota dele de maneira gratuita, ele pode
entregar pro João das Couve? Pode, de
boa, de boa. Pode entregar lá pro João
das Cove. tranquilamente. Agora, se ele
for vender, ele tem que obrigatoriamente
perguntar se o azul quer e o laranja
querem. Se for venda, se ele vende pro
João das Coves sem oferecer pro azul e
pro laranja, tanto o azul ou o laranja
podem, depositando o preço que foi pago
pelo João das Cove, em até 180 dias
requerer que seja entregue a ele o
quinhão cedido. Tá bom, Roberta? Mas e
se o laranja e o azul quiserem ao mesmo
tempo? Eles podem adquirir na proporção
das respectivas cotas hereditárias. Como
aqui é meio a meio, no caso, o a cota do
roxo seria metade pro azul, metade pro
laranja, tá bom? Beleza? Show de bola.
Então, a gente tem aqui essa regra aí.
Isso tá no 1794. Isso pode cair na sua
prova. Professora, você falou que quando
foi instaurada a partilha, a gente vai
seguir algumas regras. Que regras são
essas? Nós vamos ter duas
possibilidades.
Regras de sucessão legítima, que são as
regras previstas
na lei
sucessão legítima,
que a gente aplica as regras da lei, a
gente vai conversar sobre isso já já. Ou
se o morto tiver deixado testar
testamento, a gente segue a regra de
sucessão testar.
Mária.
E aí a gente aplica as regras
de testamento,
tá? Não cob aqui, eu vou abreviar. Tudo
bem? Dá o print nessa tela, então. Dá o
print nessa tela então.
Professora, mas eu vou fazer essas
regras aonde? Eu vou fazer essas regras
no processo de inventário. Como que
funciona essa história do inventário?
Vamos lá.
O inventário, então, ele vai servir pra
gente aplicar as regras de partilha.
Então, novamente ocorreu a morte, a
gente vai pegar a herança,
vamos dividir entre os herdeiros,
seguindo as regras de partilha,
ou as regras da lei ou a regra do
testamento.
Então, o marco inicial aqui é ter havido
a morte de alguém. Presta atenção agora.
É ter havido a morte de alguém. Ocorrida
a morte, nós vamos ter a transmissão
imediata dos bens aos herdeiros. Ou
seja, vamos passar a posse
e a propriedade
dos bens aos herdeiros. É essa situação
aqui, ó. Tá vendo que inclusive eu vou
copiar ela. É essa situação aqui dos
nossos meninin aqui. E vou colar bem
aqui, ó, pelo princípio da sizine. Tá
vendo? Exatamente essa situação aqui, ó.
Posse dos bens aos herdeiros.
Os herdeiros eles vão
ficar
ali. Pera aí que faltou aqui o o menino
aqui, ó. Não pegou o menininho aqui.
Vocês sabem que eu faço tudo ao vivo
mesmo, então não me interessa. Seguinte,
é,
pera aí, gente, que eu sou
eu sou dessas, né? Então,
como eu sou dessas
e eu tenho muito problema com
perfeccionismo
e eu sei que vocês vão estudar por esse
material depois, deixa eu fazer ele bem
arrumadinho.
Pronto.
Então, olha lá, ocorrida a morte, a
gente vai ter a transmissão, né, da
posse da propriedade aos herdeiros, tá?
Da posse propriedade aos herdeiros.
Imagina que essa morte tenha acontecido,
vamos supor aqui, uma data, dia 20.
do cinco, tá? A gente tem um um tempo
para agir,
ou seja, a gente tem um tempo para agir.
Ocorrida a morte
aqui, a gente tem que começar o
inventário.
Quanto tempo, profe, que a gente tem?
Muito simples.
Quando acontece a morte, surge a ideia
de alguém que começa a tomar conta dos
bens, que é o chamado administrador
provisório. Esse administrador
provisório, ele vai ficar tomando conta
dos bens ali, é um dos herdeiros de
maneira provisória, até que se inicie o
inventário. Iniciado o inventário, vamos
colocar aqui, ó, que o inventário
começou.
o inventário, nós vamos ter exatamente
a nomeação de um inventariante.
E aí entram as regras inventariante.
Entram as regras exatamente do Código de
Processo Civil até que ao final
termine
aplicando a partilha dos bens. O que que
você tem que levar paraa sua prova?
Muito embora o Código Civil fale que o
inventário tem que começar em 30 dias,
na verdade a gente aplica o artigo 611
do CPC, que menciona
2 meses, tá? Então, entre a morte e o
inventário, nós vamos ter 2 meses paraa
abertura. E aí o inventário vai correr.
Roberta, esse inventário ele é judicial
ou extrajudicial?
Ele pode ser judicial ou pode ser
extra judicial, tá? Nós vamos ver já já
uma uma resolução do CNJ sobre isso.
Então, até que seja feita a partilha e
os bens específicos sejam entregues aos
herdeiros, a gente tem essa situação,
né, de copropriedade, de codomínio.
Professora, vamos lá.
Esses herdeiros, eles entram na posse e
na propriedade dos bens. Mas é fato que
isso é uma ficção, devendo esses
herdeiros promover, atenção agora,
a aceitação,
a aceitação
ou a renúncia,
tá? a aceitação ou a renúncia.
A aceitação
que tá lá no artigo 184,
a pessoa vai confirmar o que ela quer
realmente receber a herança. E a
renúncia que tá lá no 1806,
em que a pessoa vai falar assim: "Não,
eu não quero a herança, eu não vou
receber essa herança". Muito cuidado,
porque aceitação
ela pode ser
expressa quando a pessoa faz um
documento ou no cartório ou no processo,
mas também ela pode ser tácita,
tá? Então a aceitação, como ela é uma
confirmação daquilo que já aconteceu lá
com a morte, né, com o princípio da
saizine, ela pode ser expressa ou tá.
Isso aqui cai muito em prova. A
renúncia, por sua vez, não. A renúncia
ela tem que ser o quê, pessoal? Expressa
sempre. Ou ou por termo nos autos
do processo, né? Você vai lá e faz uma
petição escrita dizendo que você tá
renunciando
ou
por escritura pública. Você vai lá no
cartório e faz uma escritura pública
dizendo que você está renunciando.
Agora, sobre o inventário, a gente tem
uma resolução do CNJ.
Essa resolução do CNJ, ela é uma
resolução bastante importante, porque
ela traz uma regra nova. Essa resolução
é teoricamente nova, ela é de 2024, é a
resolução 571 de 2024, que fala do
inventário no cartório, que é o
extrajudicial, e o inventário judicial.
Antes dessa resolução, nós tínhamos a
informação de que o inventário e o
divórcio no cartório somente poderiam
ser feitos quando houvesse consenso e
ausência de pessoas incapazes. Então
vocês têm aí, né, até hoje a
mentalidade, alguns tm de que inventário
e partilha de inventári ou blá
inventário e divórcio só podem ser
feitos no cartório quando houver pleno e
completo consenso e ausência de
incapazes. Na verdade, essa resolução
mudou, tá? A gente tem agora aqui o
seguinte, coloquei para você, olha a
resolução aqui. Essa resolução aqui, ela
diz o seguinte: resolução
de 2024
do CNJ.
Essa resolução traz informação categoria
pra gente. Que informação é essa, profe?
Olha lá. O inventário poderá ser
realizado, tá? O inventário poderá ser
realizado por escritura pública, ainda
que inclua interessado menor ou incapaz,
desde que o pagamento do seu quinhão
hereditário ou de sua ameação, ocorra em
parte ideal em cada um dos bens
inventariados e haja manifestação
favorável do Ministério Público. Então
hoje o inventário e a partilha pode ser
extrajudicial,
mesmo havendo herdeiros incapazes,
garantindo aí a participação evidente do
Ministério Público. E se houver
nascituro do autor da herança para a
lavratura do termo de inventário,
aguardar-se ao registro do seu
nascimento com a indicação da
parentalidade ou comprovação de não ter
nascido com vida, que é o na morto. OK?
Veja que a eficácia dessa escritura
pública de inventário com interessado
menor ou incapaz dependerá de
manifestação favorável do Ministério
Público. Então, a gente tem aqui que o
Ministério Público ele precisa
participar nesses casos, tá? E o
tabelião de notas, ele vai encaminhar o
expediente ao respectivo Ministério
Público. E se o Ministério Público
impugnar falando que não concorda, o
procedimento deverá ir para o juízo
competente. Então hoje tanto o
inventário quanto o divórcio podem ser
feitos no cartório de maneira
extrajudicial, ainda que tenha
incapazes, mas deve ser categoricamente
ouvido o Ministério Público. Tá bom? Aí
vamos lá. Como a gente falou aqui de
aceitação e de renúncia, a renúncia ela
é significa, né, abrir mão da herança.
Eu chego e falo assim: "Olha, eu não
quero mais eh eu não quero receber essa
herança. Eu eh meu tio deixou aqui uma
herança para mim. Eu não quero receber,
tô fora, vou renunciar. Eu abro mão.
Quando uma pessoa renuncia, a cota que
ela renunciou acresce paraos demais
herdeiros, ou seja, será distribuída
entre os demais herdeiros, ignorando a
existência daquela pessoa.
Mas aí tem uma parada, olha isso. Vamos
falar disso. Dá o print aí.
Uma questão de prova. Eu agora quero que
você preste muita atenção, porque nós
estamos diante de uma questão de
prova.
Atenção, produção.
Imagina você
que
o João
é credor,
tá? O João é credor
de Maria.
O João é credor de Maria
no valor
de R$ 50.000.
Sei lá, por uma questão qualquer, o João
emprestou dinheiro paraa Maria. Ou seja,
o João é o credor, a Maria é a devedora
dele,
tá?
Quando alguém é credor, você sabe
que esse credor ele fica olhando ali,
né? Ele fica de olho em tudo que
acontece com o devedor. Por quê? Na hora
que entrar um dinheiro, ele vai lá e pá,
penhora. A Maria é devedora e a Maria
não tem dinheiro nenhum, nada, nada,
nada, nada, nada, nada. O João já tá
tentando receber esse dinheiro dele,
rapaz. já tem é tempo, ele já tá
tentando receber já faz, é dias, meses,
anos até. E ele tá lá de olho na
situação.
De repente acontece uma cena.
Que cena, professora? O Zé das Cove, que
é o pai da Maria, ele morre e ele deixa
uma herança líquida de R$ 300.000 R$
1.000 para ser dividida entre, ficou
horrível isso, né?
Entre os seus três filhos.
Sabe quem são os filhos do Zé? Você vai
ficar chocado agora.
O João, não é João porque João é o nome
do credor. O
a Maria,
o Antônio
e o Nivaldo.
São os filhos do José.
Veja que em condições normais
cada filho desse recebe 100.000, né?
Condições normais.
E aí, como o Zé morreu, imediatamente
pela Saisine, transmite-se a posse
propriedade dos Mens aos filhos.
Duneida.
Dida. Sabe o que que a Maria faz?
A Maria simplesmente pega aqui, ó, vai
receber os 100.000 e fala: "Eu não vou
receber nada, eu vou renunciar."
A Maria simplesmente
faz uma renúncia dizendo: "Eu não quero
os R$ 100.000". Claro que ela tá fazendo
de sacanagem. E como o João
é o credor, ele tá bem muito de olho no
que ela fez.
Nesse caso aqui, sabe o que que vai
acontecer?
O João vai observar um artigo muito
cobrado em prova, que é simplesmente
o 1813.
Professora, o que que esse artigo faz?
Esse artigo é uma bênção na vida do
sujeito credor 1813.
Sabe o que que diz o 1813?
Esse 1813, gente, ele diz que o credor
que presencia uma cena dessa, né,
ridícula, deixa eu arrumar isso aqui,
que presencia uma cena dessa, ele
simplesmente
pode aceitar a herança no lugar do
menino renunciante.
Professora, como assim? Olha isso. Vou
colocar para você aqui agora, porque
como a gente tem essa questão já cobrada
várias vezes, vai que o examinador faz
de novo, né? Vai que o examinador chega
e fala: "Vou cobrar isso aqui de novo,
porque eu vou dar a pontuação para os
meninos da Roberta". Olha só, o 1813 diz
o seguinte: "Quando o menino
renunciante, quando o herdeiro
prejudicar seus credores a Maria
prejudicando,
renunciando à herança, poderão os
credores com autorização do juiz
aceitá-la em nome do renunciante."
Então, o que que o João vai fazer? O
João simplesmente quando ele visualiza
essa história, ele vai aceitar. Olha lá,
o João
vai aceitar
a herança no lugar da Maria. Ele vai
falar: "Juiz, a Maria renunciou, mas eu
venho aqui aceitar". Só que para ele
fazer isso, ele tem um prazo e esse
prazo é de 30 dias e já caiu isso na
prova. Olha lá, a habilitação se fará no
prazo de 30 dias seguintes ao
conhecimento do fato. Então, se a
renúncia já aconteceu tem 6 meses, mas
eu só fiquei sabendo agora, o meu prazo
de 30 dias só começa a contar agora. E
aí, como que vai ficar essa história? O
João aceita. Quanto que era a cota da
Maria? Quanto que era a cota? O João
aceita a cota da Maria que era 100. E aí
a gente vai ter o abatimento
da dívida que é de 50. Quanto que sobra?
50. Então o saldo remanescente, né, paga
a dívida. O remanescente que é esse
troco aqui, vou botar aqui, ó, dívida.
cota sem dívida. O saldo remanescente,
que é o troco, será devolvido aos demais
herdeiros. Ou seja, em relação ao troco
permanece
a renúncia.
De modo que esse troco aqui será
partilhado entre quem? entre o Antônio e
o Nivaldo, porque a gente vai agir como
se a Maria tivesse realmente renunciado.
Tudo bem, Maravigold, Maravigold, né?
Então, dá o print nessa tela. Matéria
muito importante para você. Muitíssimo,
muitíssimo, muitíssimo importante para
você.
Tudo bem? Então, renunciou, tem dívida,
meu amigo, o seguinte é: eu vou aceitar
esta dívida no seu lugar. Manda para mim
no chat se tá tudo bem, se você tá
entendendo a matéria, se você tá,
principalmente, sobretudo gostando do
nosso encontro de hoje. E mais um
golinho no café pra gente seguir. Lembra
que eu falei no começo
que a gente vai aplicar as regras de
partilha?
Seguinte,
é, professora,
quais são essas regras? Que regras são
que regras são essas, né? Que regras são
essas? Vamos ao nossos desenhos. Olha
lá. Então, questão de prova, tudo OK?
Deu o print? Não vai esquecer quais são
as regras de partilha.
Afinal de contas, a gente vai falar o
quê? Bom, eu falei para você que quando
a gente vai fazer aqui, ó,
as regras de partilha, nós temos dois
caminhos,
dois caminhos
a seguir,
tá? Regra de partilha, nós temos dois
caminhos a seguir. Nós podemos seguir
as regras
que a professora não sabe desenhar mais.
As regras de partilha prevista em lei,
tá vendo aqui?
E podemos utilizar as regras de partilha
previstas em um
testamento.
Vocês vão pirar agora porque vocês vão
entender
quase 5 anos de faculdade em alguns
minutos.
Quando é que eu vou aplicar as regras de
sucessão
previstas na [limpando a garganta] lei?
é o que a gente chama de sucessão
legítima,
tá? sucessão legítima e as de
testamento, o que a gente chama de
sucessão
testamentária.
OK? A sucessão legítima,
a gente entrega os bens aos chamados
herdeiros.
legítimos.
E quem são herdeiros legítimos? Quem a
lei diz que é herdeiro legítimo?
Essa informação está no 1829.
Quem a lei diz que é herdeiro? São
herdeiros legítimos, tá? A sucessão
testamentária
é aquela que eu aplico as regras
entregando os herdeiros.
que estejam previstos no testamento, que
são os herdeiros testamentários.
Nem todo mundo faz testamento, aliás, é
bem raro até, tá? Mas quem são os
herdeiros legítimos previstos na lei?
São eles os
descendentes de quem? do morto, óbvio.
Os ascendentes
de quem? Do morto, óbvio.
O cônjuge ou companheiro de quem? Do
morto. Óbvio.
E os colaterais
até o quarto grau de quem? Do morto,
óbvio. E quem são essas pessoas?
Irmãos
do morto. Óbvio.
Sobrinhos de quem? Do morto. Óbvio.
Tios de quem? Do morto. Óbvio. E primos
de quem? do morto. Óbvio, quando a gente
fala colaterais até o quarto grau, irmão
é segundo grau, sobrinho é terceiro
grau, tio é terceiro grau e primo é
quarto grau. Olha para mim,
tio e sobrinho são herdeiros de terceiro
grau colateral,
óbvio,
mas eles não concorrem entre si. Quando
a gente fala concorre entre si, é, eles
não dividem a herança entre si.
Nani não, eles não dividem a herança
entre si. Na verdade, o sobrinho tem
preferência. Então, se eu tenho uma
pessoa que morreu e essa pessoa tem tios
e sobrinhos, os sobrinhos têm
preferência em relação aos tios. OK?
Vamos lá. E tem um detalhe importante
aqui.
Tem um detalhe importante. Categoria.
Quando a gente coloca aqui o coração, é
representando o cônjuge
de quem? Do morto, óbvio.
Ou o companheiro
do morto. Óbvio. Professora, tem como
uma pessoa ter cônjuge e companheiro ao
mesmo tempo? Eu vou até dar um gole no
meu café que já tá frio, mas eu fico
chateada quando alguém me fala uma coisa
dessa.
Eu dou na sua cara, eu vou na sua casa
e eu esprego a sua cara no chapisco.
Se você disser para mim
que o cônjuge e o companheiro do morto,
deixa eu te falar, só tem como ter um no
Brasil. Essa regra ainda é clara,
Arnaldo.
Ou tem cônjuge ou tem companheiro. Os
dois, meu querido, não vai tá dando.
Infelizmente não vamos estar podendo
ajudar. ou é o cônjuge ou é o
companheiro. Por quê? Se você tem
cônjuge, o outro é amante.
E já dizia Marília Mendonça, amante não
tem lá.
Entendo que deveria ter, mas é um
entendimento meu, Roberta, tá? Meu
Roberta.
Mas vamos lá.
Por, professora, não vem ao caso, que a
gente tá estudando para OAB. O AB OAB
não vai cobrar isso, mas faz a
pós-graduação aqui do Gran.
que aí a gente vai ter esse tipo de tema
para comentar, tá? Vamos, aliás, eu
tenho coordenação de três cursos de pós
aqui maravilhosos. Deixa eu dar uma
pausa para o meu jabá. Direito
imobiliário e condominial,
advocacia privada,
ensino tudo e
direito do consumidor. Seguinte, é,
volta. Então, vamos lá.
Descendente, ascendente, cônjuge ou
companheiro.
Os colaterais até o quarto grau. Aí,
esses são os herdeiros legítimos, tá?
Esses aqui, produção, vou até fazer a
caneta
categoria. Esses são herdeiros
legítimos.
Professora, e dessa galera aí de
herdeiro legítimo?
Não tem uma parada que é herdeiro
necessário? Tem. Sabe quem é esse povo
aqui, ó?
Esses três são herdeiros necessários.
Sabia disso? Porque veja, lembra que o
conjunto patrimonial,
o conjunto patrimonial ele é
aquela bola? Vamos desenhar aquela bola
aqui de novo.
O conjunto patrimonial não é esse?
Imagina que a pessoa morreu deixando
R 1 milhão deais.
O conjunto patrimonial dela aqui é R 1
milhãoa.
Ô Alícia, um beijo, viu? Vem para mim
após.
Muito melhor. [risadas]
R 1 milhão deais.
Essa herança, ela pode ser vista como um
todo, 1 milhão deais, tá? Vista como um
todo. Ou eu posso dividir aqui no meio.
Como assim, professora? Porque eu sempre
posso fazer testamento. Se eu divido no
meio, eu tenho 500k, 500.000 de um lado,
500.000 de outro. Não tem. Curte agora,
curte agora. Eu vou dividir em duas
cotas.
em duas cotas.
Esse lado aqui
azul
de 500.000 e o outro lado vamos colocar
de rosinha
de 500.000. Tá vendo aqui?
Dividir em dois pedaços.
E pois vem, Alice. Alice, eu vou amar. E
olha que interessante,
se você tem, porque veja, a gente tá
falando aqui do lado do testamento, eu
sempre posso fazer um testamento.
Ué, Roberto, eu achei que não, mas você
sempre pode, sempre pode deixar um
testamento.
Ai, professora, eu sempre posso testar.
Sempre, sempre, sempre,
sempre. Eu sempre posso fazer um
testamento. A grande diferença
é que se você tem herdeiro necessário,
olha que sensacional.
Se você tem herdeiro necessário, você só
pode dispor em testamento
metade. Vou fazer assim, ó.
Ou seja, eu posso dispor 500, nesse
exemplo aqui de 1.500.000,
que a gente vai chamar de parte, sabe o
quê? Disponível.
E os outros 50 eu tenho que deixar
obrigatoriamente entre os herdeiros
necessários, que a gente vai chamar de
legítima.
parte disponível e legítima. Ai,
professora, pelo amor de Deus, Jorge
Mateus, eu entendi. E lhe digo mais,
essa parte disponível eu deixo para quem
eu quiser.
Ah, professora, entender. Entendeu?
Então vamos ver se você entendeu mesmo.
Pula,
joga a câmera em mim. Olha para cá.
Deixa eu fazer um caso
de um caso repentino de prova. Veja bem,
veja bem, meu bem. Olha para cá.
Imagina você. Então, eu posso fazer o
que eu quiser, né? Com testamento.
Posso. Imagina esse caso aqui, ó.
Vamos soltar
soltar um caso aqui. A Maria,
ela tem três filhos e toda vez que você
tá falando de sucessão,
você vai desenhar.
É, começou a ler uma questão de
sucessão, meu Deus, misericórdia do Pai,
comece a desenhar.
Não desdenha a prova, desenha a prova,
tá? Então vamos lá. A Maria, a Maria ela
tem três filhos.
Filho um,
filho dois e filho três. E a Maria tem
um patrimônio de 1 milhão.
1 milhão.
Ainda em vida, a Maria fez um testamento
dispondo a parte disponível.
a parte disponível
para o filho um.
E aí a Maria foi lá e morreu.
Maria foi lá e morreu. Professora, pelo
amor de Deus, como que vai ficar essa
divisão? Aí a gente vai fazer nossa
bolinha.
Quanto que era o patrimônio da Maria? 1
milhão.
Se a Maria tem filhos, a minha pergunta
é: esses filhos são herdeiros
necessários?
São herdeiros necessários. Se são
herdeiros necessários, o que que é a
parte disponível do patrimônio da Maria?
É a metade. Então, a gente faz o quê?
Passa a linha no meio.
A parte disponível a nossa gloriosa
Maria deixou para quem? Produção, deixou
a parte disponível
para o filho um.
Então, o filho um já vai receber aqui R$
500.000.
Ah, professora, mas ela pode fazer isso?
Pode, porque a gente não consignou aqui
que o testamento você pode deixar para
quem você quiser. Pois muito que bem,
deixou para o menino filho um.
E os outros 50%, que é a chamada
legítima. A legítima a gente tem que
dividir entre os herdeiros necessários.
Então essa parte legítima, como são três
herdeiros necessários, eu divido por por
três. Eu divido entre o filho um, o
filho dois e o filho 3. Então o filho um
vai receber 500.000.
Agora chega o momento, profe burrinha,
que eu tenho que pegar a calculadora
e dividir 500 por 3. Cabe quanto que dá.
500 di por 3.
Ah, gente, não me julga
que nem um meme que eu vi no Instagram
assim, eu tenho medo do meu marido pegar
meu telefone
e de ver o quê? abrir calculadora e ter
uma conta assim. [risadas]
A gente vai olhar e vai falar: "Porra,
que mulher burra, não consegue fazer de
não consigo.
Não me julga. Então ele vai receber 500.
1000 + 166,6.
O filho dois vai receber 166,
66 e o filho 3
166 e 66. Então o filho um recebe
500.000 de testamento e 166 e 66 de
legítima e o F2 de legítima e o F3 de
legítima. Nossa, professora. Então pode
contemplar o menino aqui, o claro
e é sobre a Ah, poderia deixar pro João,
pode pro Zé das Cove, pode. Posso deixar
para criar uma fundação? Com certeza.
Pode, pode. Tudo bem. Então, a ideia é,
eu sempre posso testar, dá uma olhada no
material, sempre posso testar. Dá o
print nessa tela aí. Eu sempre posso
testar, né? É, professora, mas com
quantos anos que eu posso fazer
testamento?
Que idade?
16 anos.
Eu sempre posso testar a partir dos 16
anos. Professora, eu posso testar a
partir dos 16 anos, mesmo se eu não
tiver menino lá, como é o nome?
emancipado? Sim, mesmo se eu não tiver
com os meus pais, sim, porque a
capacidade para testar é aos 16 anos.
Aliás, nós temos de forma eh de
testamento, nós temos duas situações.
Nós temos as formas ordinárias,
rapidinho aqui, ordinárias,
que são as formas tradicionais.
e as formas
especiais
de testamento. Quais são as formas
ordinárias? Quem é que se a lembra?
Professor, ele pode deixar em testamento
que ele recebe esse valor e não terá
direito à divisão da outra parte. Não
tem como, porque a outra parte é
legítima, né?
É legítima.
Formas ordinárias. Eu tenho testamento
público
que é feito no cartório, tudo bonitinho.
O testamento cerrado, que você pode
fazer de próprio punho e só registrar no
cartório.
E o testamento particular, que é feito
de forma particular. Toda modalidade de
testamento ordinário, ele é escrito, tá?
Não existe para os particulares
testamento oral. Todo testamento ali é
escrito e a pessoa cega, a única forma
que ela pode testar é de forma pública.
OK?
As formas especiais são o marítimo,
quando você tá lá a bordo do navio e tá
morrendo,
o aeronáutico,
quando você tá a bordo da aeronave, do
avião e tá morrendo, e o militar, para
aquelas pessoas que estão a serviços
militares,
estão na linha de frente. É a única
forma que você pode ter de testamento
oral é o testamento militar. Mas veja
que essas formas especiais são situações
excepcionais. Você tá lá no navio, tá
morrendo, sente que vou morrer. Chama o
comandante, faz o seu testamento, ele
registra no livro de bordo. Avião, tô no
avião, vou ter um mal súbito aqui,
gente. Socorro, Deus. Quero fazer meu
testamento. Rápido, rápido, chama a
pessoa designada pelo comandante, porque
se o comandante largar o volante do
avião, o avião cai,
tá? Beleza? E o militar que tá lá na
linha de frente, de repente tomou um
tiro.
Soldado Ryan, né? Resgate do soldado
Brian, sei lá o nome, se é Brian, Brian,
sei lá. É Brian. E aí ele tá morrendo lá
e ele quer fazer um testamento, ele
chama o povo. Gente, eu vou falar meu
testamento, fal testamento, morre.
Lembrando que essas formas especiais a
pessoa tem que morrer dentro de 90 dias
do desembarque, cade que senão não tem
mais efeito.
Então eu sempre posso testar. Agora uma
questão bastante interessante de prova é
o seguinte, vamos lá no material. Dá o
print nessa tela aí. Eu sei que eu
sempre posso fazer meu testamento, nera?
Então tá.
Então, dica
do coração.
Dica do coração só para quem quer ser
aprovado mesmo. Dica do coração. Eu
sempre
eu sempre
posso testar. Não foi isso que a gente
falou? Sim. A diferença é que se
eu
tenho herdeiro necessário, quem é
herdeiro necessário mesmo? Vamos
recordar, porque recordar é viver.
Descendente, ascendente, cuge,
companheiro. Descendente, ascendente,
conjuge ou companheiro. Descendente,
ascendente, conjugou companheiro. Eu
sempre posso testar, mas se eu tenho
herdeiro necessário,
eu só posso
até 50%.
Tudo bem?
Eu só posso 50%. Professora, eu não
posso deixar os filhos sem herança, não.
Porque se eu tenho herdeiro necessário,
eles têm que receber da legítima, tá? A
diferença é o seguinte, e isso aqui
sempre cai, sempre cai
na FGV,
sempre cai. Dá até preguiça do tanto que
a FGV cobra isso em OAB e a gente não
vai cair nisso, tá? FGV. Se eu tenho
herdeiro necessário, presta atenção
agora.
Se eu tenho herdeiro necessário,
eu vou lá e faço um testamento. Ou seja,
o herdeiro necessário já existe. Eu vou
lá e faço um testamento dispondo mais do
que 50% dos meus bens. Tá certo isso?
Não, tá errado. Eu botei mais do que o
que eu poderia. Qual vai ser a saída
quando eu morrer e o povo abrir o meu
testamento?
A saída será redução
testamentária. Ou seja, o juiz vai pegar
o seu testamento e vai reduzir
para encaixar dentro dos 50.
Tipo, deixo 60% dos meus bens para o meu
irmão. Ora, eu tenho um herdeiro
necessário, eu não posso fazer isso. Eu
tenho que deixar até 50%. Que que o juiz
faz? Vai lá e e reduz a disposição
testamentária para ajustar dentro dos
50. Agora imagina que eu não tenho
herdeiro necessário, eu vou lá e faço um
testamento.
Isso aqui já caiu em prova também, tá?
Eu não tenho herdeiro necessário. Eu vou
lá e faço um testamento. Eu faço um
testamento dispondo lá o valor
qualquer paraa minha amiga, porque eu
realmente não tinha herdeiro necessário.
Imagine, eu não tenho descendente, não
tenho ascendente, não tenho cônjuge nem
companheiro. E eu vou lá ser felizinha
da minha vida e deixo todas os todo o
meu patrimônio pra minha amiga. Eu
posso? Posso, porque no ato da feitura
do testamento eu não tinha herdeiro
necessário e vou levar minha vida. Já
muito discrente, desolada,
desesperançosa da vida, eu estou
caminhando no parque e puf, encontro o
amor da minha vida. Ora, encontrei o
presente de Deus, porque tudo que eu
tinha encontrado até este momento era
apenas uma lembrancinha. Encontrei o
presente de Deus, me apaixono e tenho
filho. Ora, o herdeiro necessário,
descendente e o cônjuge surgiram depois
do testamento. Aí eu esqueci, deixei
aquele testamento lá, esqueci que eu
tinha um testamento, ó, fui levar a vida
e eu tinha que revogar, não revoguei,
fui fazer essa palhaçada toda de viver a
vida feliz da vida.
E aí o herdeiro necessário surgiu depois
do testamento
e minha vida continuou. De modo que
quando o juiz abriu o meu testamento,
ele viu que eu tinha deixado tudo pro
meu amigo.
Eu tinha deixado tudo pro meu amigo.
Professora, nesse caso, o que que vai
acontecer? Eu vou reduzir? Não é caso de
redução, é caso, sabe de quê? Rompimento
do testamento. Romento
do testamento. É caso de rompimento
do testamento. O juiz vai pegar o
testamento, vai rasgar o testamento
e quem vai receber a herança integral
não é quem estava no testamento, é, na
verdade quem eh é considerado herdeiro
necessário. Então, memoriza isso, pelo
amor de Deus, Jorge Mateus, tá? Memoriza
isso. Por quê? Porque quando a gente
fala de cumprimento de testamento, a
gente tem duas situações diferentes. A
primeira, o herdeiro necessário que já
existe, a pessoa faz um testamento
ultrapassando a cota de 50%, é caso de
redução do testamento. Se você faz o
testamento
deixando é sem ter herdeiro necessário e
o herdeiro necessário surge depois, é
caso de rompimento do testamento, tá?
Então, por favor,
por favor, memoriza essa tela, dá o
print nessa tela
e vamos seguir o bonde aqui, tá?
Eu
vou até abrir aqui
um negócio aqui,
porque se der tempo
eu vou
fazer uma coisa, uma coisa nunca feita
na história desse Brasil.
Brincadeira.
Deixa eu já verificar aqui.
Vocês acham que eu sei mexer?
Não sabemos estar mexendo
porque a FGV, e eu vou tentar achar isso
aqui, já cobrou uma questão exatamente
sobre redução e sobre rompimento. Então
você tem que ter muito, muito cuidado.
Nós estamos diante de um testamento que
é feito,
né, que amostra grátis que é feito
na existência de herdeiro necessário,
você tem que respeitar a regra.
Não pode ultrapassar 50%. De modo que
haverá uma redução da disposição
testamentária, porque quando você deixa
o testamento, haverá uma abertura do
testamento para esse caso, né? Então tem
que ter cuidado com isso. E essa
abertura é um procedimento judicial. Se
você não tem o testamento ou não tem
herdeiro necessário, perdão, não tem
herdeiro necessário, deixa o testamento
dispondo alguma coisa e o herdeiro
necessário surge depois, de fato, é caso
de rompimento do testamento, tá bom?
Rompimento do testamento. Então, vamos
voltar lá no material. Então, eu quero
que você dê o print nessa tela aqui e
veja que você sempre pode fazer o
testamento. A grande, o grande X da
questão é se você faz o testamento, você
vai observar
que eh tem que respeitar a regra da
legítima se houver herdeiro necessário.
Agora, quem que é considerado herdeiro
legítimo? Vamos fazer um desenho aqui
agora,
porque de sucessão legítima você tem que
ter bonitinho na sua cabeça tudo
registrado. Então vamos lá. Sucessão
legítima.
Alguém já até perguntou aí no chat sobre
regime de bens. A gente vai ver agora.
Sucessão legítima. Eu vou aplicar as
regras da lei, basicamente o artigo 1829
do Código Civil, tá?
E aí o 1829 ele traz
a chamada ordem
de vocação
hereditário.
Ordem de vocação hereditária. Shirley,
um beijo, viu? Obrigada. E essa ordem de
vocação hereditária é uma ordem mesmo. A
herança será deferida na seguinte ordem.
Primeiro, para quem mesmo? Para quem
mesmo? Um.
Aos
descendentes de quem? Do morto. Óbvio.
Não havendo. Olha o que eu tô dizendo a
você. Não havendo
Não havendo
e é descendente,
não havendo descendente, eu vou para os
ascendentes,
tá? Eu vou para os ascendentes.
Roberta, como assim? Ora, não havendo
descendentes, eu vou para os
ascendentes.
Dentro dos descendentes, quem que são os
descendentes do morto? Quem são os
descendentes do morto?
Veja, descendentes do morto são quem tá
quem está quem estiver abaixo do morto.
Então, eu tenho filho e primeiro eu vou
entregar pros filhos. Não havendo os
filhos, eu vou entregar pros netos. Não
havendo netos, eu vou entregar pros
bisnetos e por aí vai. Eu só desço pra
classe anterior.
Eu só desço pra classe anterior quando
não houver quando não houver
ninguém
na classe antecedente. Então eu só vou
descer para neto se não houver se não
houver o quê? Se não houver os filhos.
Eu só vou descer
para bisneto se não houver o quê? O
neto. E por aí vai.
E por aí vai, tá? Então, muito cuidado
com isso, por a gente vai observar que é
não é todo mundo no bolo. Não é todo
mundo no bolo. É o quê, gente? É
na ordem de vocação hereditária, tá?
Se não houver descendente, vai para os
ascendentes. Mas dentro dos ascendentes,
eu tenho pai e mãe.
Se não houver pai, mãe, avô, avó. Se não
houver avô, avó, bisavô, bisavó e por aí
vai.
Se eu não tenho descendente nem
ascendente, a herança vai integralmente
para o cônjuge.
O cônjuge ou o companheiro de quem? Do
morto.
Do morto, óbvio.
Tá? vai para o sujeito
eh que esteja convivendo com o morto.
Claro e evidente.
Professora,
e se não houver
cônjuge?
E se não houver cônjuge ou companheiro?
do morto. A herança vai para quem? Aí eu
já te expliquei.
Vai para quem tá em quarto lugar. Quem
tá em quarto lugar são os colaterais.
Até que grau, pelo amor de Deus? Quarto
grau. Aqui nos colaterais a gente também
tem uma ordem. Que ordem, profe?
Irmãos
do morto.
Não havendo irmãos,
sobrinho do morto. Não havendo sobrinho,
tio do morto. Não havendo tio do morto,
vai para o
primo do morto. Qual que é o grau aqui?
Segundo,
terceiro,
quarto.
Só que tem um detalhe, gente. Essa linha
é uma linha de vocação hereditária. Olha
a caneta mágica deixando para você aqui,
ó,
uma seta para você não esquecer.
Ó, virou um coração. Que lindo. Para
você não esquecer.
que a ordem é essa.
Então eu só desço para
para sua eh
classe anterior ou classe subsequente se
não houver a anterior. Só que o 1829,
gente, ele faz uma coisa, professora,
que coisa é essa? Eu tô tentando entrar
aqui no Gran Questões, mas eu acho que
ele não tá, o site deve tá ou
sobrecarregado ou alguma coisa. Ele não
tá entrando. Eu queria mostrar umas
questões para vocês de sucessão, mas não
tá entrando de jeito nenhum.
Hum, hum.
Ele fica rodando, rodando.
Não sei se é só aqui,
ó. Queria mostrar um negócio para vocês,
mas vamos seguindo aqui. De repente, em
algum momento aqui entra
eh
não vai, deve tá deve ter algum
probleminha aqui, mas vamos lá. Olha só,
então, quando você fala de descendentes,
pode ser que o morto tenha deixado
descendentes, mas também tenha deixado
o mozão, né? Não pode. Pode. Se ele
tiver deixado descendentes e o mozão, o
mozão vai dividir com os descendentes.
Da mesma forma, ascendentes
dividindo
com o mozão. Ficou tortinho, né? Vamos
arrumar.
dividindo com o mozão. E o mozão vai
receber sozinho se não tiver nem a
descendente, nem ascendente.
Quando o mozão, presta atenção agora,
estiver concorrendo
com os ascendentes, o mozão aqui, ele
vai receber. Vou até fazer um
circulozinho aqui, ó, bem bonitinho.
Quando ele tiver concorrendo com
os ascendentes,
ele vai concorrer,
sabia disso?
qualquer
que seja o regime
de bens que ele era casado ou convivia
com o morto, qualquer que seja o regime
de bens.
E se ele estiver
aqui para receber sozinho,
mesma coisa. Ele vai receber sozinho
qualquer
que seja [roncando]
o regime de bens, que ele era casado ou
convivia com o morto.
Mas quando ele, o mozão,
for dividir com os descendentes,
aqui tem um porém,
porque aqui depende do regime.
A gente tem quando
Sim, ele concorre.
E quando
não, ele não concorre.
Professora, como assim?
vai depender do regime.
O cônjuge ou companheiro do morto vai
concorrer com os descendentes do morto a
depender do regime.
A depender do regime. E o 1829
ele diz, deixa eu tentar abrir para você
aqui, o 1829.
Ele diz o seguinte, curte aqui, ó.
Tudo que a gente tá falando, tá vendo?
Voltou,
voltou.
Vou. É porque eu fiz besteira, eu meti a
mão aqui no microfone.
Calma, gente, calma. Voltou.
Então, vamos lá de novo. Vou repetir. O
1829,
ele trabalha a regra que leva em
consideração o regime de bens. Voltou.
Me irrita não.
Ô professora, ficou sem sol, pelo amor,
eu meti a mão aqui no microfone.
Desculpa. Foi mal. Então vamos lá.
Voltando. O 1829 ele diz o seguinte:
o cônjuge ou companheiro,
ele não pode ter, eles não podem ter
tratamentos diferenciados.
O companheiro já teve um tratamento
diferenciado pelo 1790, que é o que eu
tava falando aqui, mas ele teve o
tratamento diferenciado
no início do código. Logo depois o
Supremo, ai fiquei nervosa aqui por
causa do som. Calma. Logo depois, o
Supremo declarou a inconstitucionalidade
do artigo 1790, que tratava o
companheiro de maneira diferente. Então
hoje a gente tem aqui, ó, o 1829.
A sucessão legítima defere-se na
seguinte ordem, que é a ordem de vocação
hereditária, que nós estamos falando
aqui. Tá vendo? Pois muito que bem. Aos
descendentes.
Aos descendentes em concorrência. Quando
a gente fala concorrência, é o quê?
Dividindo com o cônjuge sobrevivente. Aí
a gente vai interpretar, fazendo uma
interpretação extensiva e adicionando
também o companheiro. Então, cônjuge ou
companheiro, não tem como ter os dois.
Ah, mas eu quero. Vai ficar querendo.
Não tem como ter os dois.
salvo, ou seja, não não
vai dividir com os descendentes
se for casado ou convive este cônjuge ou
companheiro sobrevivente no regime da
comunhão universal, da separação
obrigatória de bens ou no regime da
comunhão parcial de bens, o autor da
herança não houver deixado bens
particulares.
Então, a gente vai ter que anotar aqui
quando é que sim e quando é que não
concorre. Quando é que sim concorre?
Concorre quando for.
Vamos botar aqui de cinza. concorre
quando for comunhão parcial de bens e o
morto tiver deixado bens particulares.
Então ele vai concorrer só nos bens
particulares,
na separação convencional de bens. E aí
eu sugiro você assistir o nosso próximo
encontro que é sobre direito das
famílias e participação final nos
acquestos.
não concorre na comunhão universal de
bens, na comunhão parcial de bens
bens particulares
e no regime da separação obrigatória de
bens. No regime da separação obrigatória
de bens, tá? Não vai concorrer. Tudo
bem? Não vai concorrer,
professora. Então, quando eu tiver
falando de ascendente, não vai ter
problema nenhum, não. Nenhum. Por quê?
Porque não estamos diante de regras
relacionadas a regime de bens, tá? Vamos
fazer alguns cálculos aqui, só pra gente
observar.
Vamos fazer? Vamos fazer sim. Vamos
fazer sim.
Vamos pegar aqui esse povo.
Vamos copiar. C de que nós não é best.
Vamos colar assim, ó.
E vamos observar algumas coisas, tá? Eu
quero que você olhe com muito carinho
agora
para o essas informações que eu vou
colocar para você. Gente, olha com muito
carinho agora. Preste atenção.
Presta atenção.
Presta atenção. Olha o caminhão da
aprovação passando na sua rua te
convidando a ser o próximo advogado ou
advogada da sua família. Presta atenção,
parecendo o carro do ovo.
Imagina você que a Maria
deixou o filho um,
o filho dois
e o filho três.
Eu vou dividir a herança da Maria por
três, né?
Agora
imagina você,
como essa daqui vai ser a base, eu vou
copiar. Imagina você que o filho um tem
o neto um da Maria, o filho dois tem o
neto dois, o filho três tem o neto três,
o neto quatro, tá todo mundo vivo.
Nesse caso aqui,
se a Maria morrer, deixa eu copiar essa
base aqui de novo, se a Maria morrer,
eu vou dividir a herança da Maria entre
quem? Entre os filhos. Porque os mais
próximos excluem os mais remotos. Quem é
o grau mais de vivo mais próximo que nós
temos aqui? Os filhos. Então a gente vai
pegar a herança da Maria e dividir por
três. Agora imagine essa mesma situação.
Mesma situação. Tá aqui a Maria
com o filho um. Eu tenho, gente, eu
tenho um toque que acaba comigo na minha
vida, tá? Então eu eu sou muito
perfeccionista.
Minhas petições iniciais tem desenho,
tem coisa escrita à mão, minhas defesas,
tudo. Então assim, né, pelo amor de
Deus. Aliás, o meu PDF aqui do grão AB é
todo assim feita a mão,
tá? Toda assim feita a mão. Vai ficar
gravada sim. E qualquer coisa tem lá no
meu canal Direito Como nunca se viu
também um monte de encontro de sucessões
de família de todas as matérias do
direito civil. Tudo lindo, maravilhoso.
Então vamos lá. Imagina nesse caso aqui,
se todos os filhos já forem falecidos,
todo mundo morreu em 2018, por exemplo,
e a Maria morreu agora, eu vou dividir a
herança da Maria por quanto? Ora, se eu
não tenho descendentes,
quem são os vivos agora mais próximos?
Os netos. Então, eu não vou dividir
entre o número de filhos, eu vou dividir
entre os números de netos. Eu vou
[roncando] dividir por quatro. Tudo bem?
Agora cuidado porque se a Maria, vamos
pegar o caso um de base, tá? Se a Maria
é casada com o João, aí você vai ter que
verificar o regime de bens. Então,
imagina você aqui, ó, a Maria
é casada com o João
e eles possuem três filhos, filho um,
filho dois
e filho três.
Filho um, filho dois e filho três.
Roberta, o João vai dividir a herança
com os filhos?
Depende, depende do regime de bens.
Suponha que
o João e a Maria sejam casados no regime
da comunhão parcial de bens. Vamos botar
aqui, ó, comunhão parcial de bens.
Comunhão parcial de bens é sim ou não? A
professora depende se tem ou se não tem
bem particular. Imagina
que eles casaram na comunhão parcial de
bens em 2015. e não tiveram nada antes
do casamento. Ou seja, todo o patrimônio
que eles adquiriram, que representa essa
bola patrimonial aqui, eles adquiriram
conjuntamente.
Então, eu não tenho patrimônio
particular da Maria, eu só tenho bens
comuns.
Se eu só tenho bens comuns, que foi o
que eles adquiriram onerosamente na
constância do casamento,
eu vou entregar para o João a ameação
dele.
Tá vendo aqui? Porque ele tá vivo. A
Maria morre.
O que que é a herança da Maria? Herança
da Maria é a metade do patrimônio dela.
É essa cota aqui, tá vendo?
Se ela não deixou o bem particular,
comunhão parcial de bens bens
particulares, o cônjuge divide ou não?
Não divide. Então eu vou dividir apenas
por três filhos. Agora imagina você a
mesma situação
agora colocando bens particulares.
Imagina que a Maria e o João casaram
no regime da comunhão parcial de bens no
ano de 2015.
Quando a Maria casou, ela já tinha um
apartamento.
Tá aqui o apartamento.
E juntos eles vou botar de cor
diferente. Ela já tinha um apartamento.
Vamos botar aqui de
azul.
Ela já tinha um apartamento, é um bem
particular só dela. E juntos eles
adquiriram
bens comuns. Aqui eu tenho comunhão
parcial de bens com ou sem bens
particulares.
Com sem bens particulares?
Com ou sem?
Com. A Maria tinha bens particulares,
né? Ela tinha bens particulares. E aí,
profe, nesse caso, se a Maria morre, eu
tenho que dar ameação do João para ele,
que é metade dos bens comuns.
E aí ele vai embora com a metade dele. E
eu tenho que definir o que que é a
herança da Maria. É exatamente esse
desenho que você vai fazer na vida. O
que que é a herança da Maria? Herança da
Maria é o que ela deixou. E o que que
ela deixou? Os bens particulares
e a metade
do bem comum.
Comunhão parcial de bens com bens
particulares é sim ou não? É sim ou não?
É sim, professora. O João divide com os
descendentes. É sim ou não? É sim. Mas
aí como ele já tirou a metade, da metade
eu divido só entre os filhos.
F1,
F2 e F3.
A parte de bens particulares, aí sim eu
divido por quatro. Eu vou entregar 1/4
pro João,
1/4 pro filho um, pro filho dois e pro
filho três. Entenderam? Então, quando
não tem bens particulares, divide só
entre os filhos. O cônjuge já tira a
ameação dele e vai embora.
Quando tem bens particulares,
a ameação divide só entre os filhos e os
bens particulares entre os filhos e o
cônjuge. É assim que você vai desenhar
na sua prova. Vamos pegar aqui de novo a
mesma base.
Mesma base.
Tá lá o João e a Maria casados. Vamos
supor que eles sejam casados desde 2015
na comunhão universal de bens.
Ou seja, todo patrimônio é dos dois.
Então, só tem só tem bens comuns. Você
tá vendo que o desenho de comunhão
parcial de bens bens particulares é
igualzinho
da comunhão da comunhão universal. só
tem bens comuns. Então eu tiro a ameação
do João, entrego a ameação dele para
ele, ele vai bem se embora com a ameação
dele. A herança da Maria é a metade dos
bens dela e eu vou dividir por três,
entregando apenas para os filhos. Porque
comunhão universal de bens é sim ou não?
É sim ou não? É não. Tá vendo aqui?
Comunhão parcial de bens bens
particulares, comunhão universal e
separação obrigatória.
Pegando a mesma base,
mesma base,
imagina que o João é casado com a Maria
no regime desde 2015, no regime da
separação
convencional de bens.
Deixa eu subir um pouquinho.
Tá aqui, ó.
Separação convencional de bens. Ou seja,
eles escolheram o regime da separação. A
Maria tem os bens dela, o João tem os
bens dele.
Se a Maria morre,
a herança da Maria é o quê? Os bens.
particulares.
Separação convencional de bens é sim ou
não? É sim ou não? É sim. E é a mesma
ideia da participação final nos acessos.
Eu divido por quatro. O João recebe 1/4,
o filho um, dois e o três também. Agora,
se for
separação obrigatória de bens,
Maria tem o patrimônio dela,
João tem o patrimônio dele. A grande
questão é que a separação obrigatória de
bens, ela é imposta pela lei, né? Ela é
imposta pela lei, não tem muito o que
fazer.
A separação de bens, ela é imposta pela
lei.
E o legislador falou que na separação
obrigatória de bens não concorre. Então,
se a Maria morre,
os bens deixados pela Maria, o que que é
a herança da Maria?
Os bens deixados
pela Maria, que são os bens particulares
dela, eu vou dividir só por três. E por
que que eu vou dividir só por três?
Porque eu vou entregar só para os
filhos. O João não concorre porque o
legislador não quis que ele concorresse.
Tá vendo como é simples? Então você
sempre tem que analisar o regime de
bens.
bens. Agora me deu um negócio aqui. Me
deu um negócio aqui
para falar para você. Dá o print nessa
tela aí. No final eu vou voltar todas as
telas pra gente dar o print em tudo. Mas
me deu um negócio, um negócio aqui que
eu quero falar, que eu vou falar.
Não sei por você se foi. Tantas saudades
eu senti. E de tristeza para morrer. Se
aquele adeus não pude dar, você marcou a
minha mentira. Olha só. Eh, dá uma
olhada aqui.
1831.
Não sei por, mas me deu um negócio aqui
para falar do 1831 com você. Professora.
Te deu o quê? Angústia.
ao cônjuge sobrevivente,
qualquer que seja o regime de bens,
qualquer que seja o regime de bens, será
assegurado,
sem prejuízo da participação que lhe
caiba na herança, o direito real de
habitação
relativamente ao imóvel destinado à
residência da família, desde que seja o
último daquela natureza a inventariar.
Pois me deu angústia e eu vou colocar
um saco
esse artigo aqui para você, porque é o
artigo que trabalha o direito real de
habitação.
E eu quero que você não erre se isso
cair na sua prova. Vamos lá.
Olha lá. ao cônjuge sobrevivente,
ou seja, a pessoa era casada
e morreu.
Qualquer que seja o regime de bens,
olha isso. Qualquer que seja o regime de
bens,
será assegurado que essa pessoa vai
ficar lá no imóvel
felizinha da vida,
mesmo depois da morte
do cônjuge dela.
Ah, professora, então me dá um exemplo.
Salve engano, isso caiu na OAB também, é
porque são tantas questões que às vezes
eu nem lembro direito, mas isso, salvo
engano, já caiu na prova da OAB também
numa situação mais ou menos assim, tô
pegando aqui o meu código para falar um
negócio para vocês. Mais ou menos assim,
o cara vivia, João e Maria viviam
juntos, tá? O João e a Maria viviam
juntos. E aí no meio do caminho eles
moravam na casa que era só do João,
porque ele era casado no regime da
separação de bens,
tá? Ele era casado no regime da
separação de bens. Vamos desenhar essa
questão que eu gosto dela para você não
confundir. Vamos lá. Era mais ou menos
assim, ó. O João,
vamos botar aqui, ó, questão FGV.
O João era casado com a Maria
no regime da separação convencional de
bens. Ou seja, eles escolheram o regime
da separação convencional de bens, tá,
professora?
E eles casaram em 2015. Então o João
tinha o patrimônio dele, a Maria tinha
um patrimônio dela. O João tinha dois
filhos, filho um e filho dois, que eram
filhos só dele. Não eram filhos da
Maria, era só dele. E o João, ele tinha
a casa
que era só dele, tá? Era bem particular
dele. No meio do caminho, o João morre.
Só que eles
moravam
nessa casa.
A Maria morava nessa casa com o João
e a casa era só do João.
E como João e a Maria moravam nessa casa
e era o único imóvel que o João deixou,
a Maria continuou morando nessa casa. E
os filhos da Maria queriam tirar a Maria
de lá.
Queriam tirar a Maria de lá. Tá,
professora. Mas e aí?
Eles podem tirar a Maria de lá? Não, não
podem. Por que que não podem? Porque a
Maria é o cônjuge sobrevivente em
qualquer
qualquer que seja o regime de bens.
Então, pode ser comunhão parcial,
comunhão universal, separação de bens,
qualquer separação obrigatória de bens.
Se mesmo que ela tenha ou não tenha
participação na herança,
ela tem o chamado direito real, direito
real de habitação,
desde que esse imóvel seja efetivamente
o único, o único imóvel daquela natureza
inventarial. Então aqui nesse
dispositivo nós temos o chamado direito
real de habitação.
Deixa eu botar aqui para baixo.
E um detalhe importante, tá? Um detalhe
categoria.
Esse direito real de habitação, pessoal,
ele é um direito real de habitação
incondicionado, porque não depende de
regime de bens. E ele é, sabe o quê?
Sabe o quê? Simplesmente
vitalício.
Ele é vitalício.
É até a morte da Maria. Sim, ele é
gratuito.
Ele é gratuito.
O direito real de habitação, ele vai ser
concedido ao cônjuge ou ao companheiro,
independentemente
de contrapartida.
Os os herdeiros do João não podem cobrar
aluguel da Maria.
Roberta, a Maria poderia renunciar?
Claro que poderia renunciar. Claro que
poderia renunciar. Professora, a lei
fala do cônjuge, mas o companheiro
também tem, apesar do Código Civil não
falar do cônjuge ou não falar do
companheiro,
basicamente o artigo 7º
da Lei
de 96
assegura, tá, ao companheiro também.
Eu
entendo que o artigo 1831 se aplica
também a um companheiro, porque é a
mesma ideia, tá? Só que a união estável
lá no artigo 7º da 9278, ela é mais
restrita porque ela fala que dissolvida
a união estável haverá,
né? Dissolvida a união estável por
morte. o cônjuge o companheiro
sobrevivente terá o direito real de
habitação enquanto não constituir uma
nova união ou um novo casamento.
Então lá seria mais ou menos que
temporário. Aqui a gente não tem essa
essa questão de nova convivência, novo
casamento, etc. Tá bom? Tudo bem?
Então, muito cuidado com a questão da do
direito real de habitação. Um outro
ponto que também não sei porque Cargas
d'Água me deu um trem aqui, um estalo
para falar, é sobre a colação dos bens.
Colação dos bens. Você sabe, vamos botar
aqui
um novo slide. Você sabe que, por
exemplo, o saco,
por exemplo,
o pai,
ele pode doar
um bem pro filho. Supõe que esse pai
doou um imóvel para esse filho,
tá?
Para fazer a doação, eu não preciso de
consentimento, não preciso de nada,
não preciso de absolutamente nada,
tá? O pai pode doar o bem pro filho, não
precisa de do de consentimento, de nada.
Eu tenho aqui a incidência do artigo 54.
Porém,
quando esse pai falecer,
esse filho que recebeu o bem, ele deve
colacionar
no inventário
que ele recebeu esse bem.
Ele vai colacionar no inventário que ele
recebeu esse bem. OK?
Colacionar significa informar.
Ele vai informar
que ele já recebeu X bens em vida. Por
quê? Porque nós vamos ter o abatimento.
Aí a gente vai ter a incidência. Vamos
aqui no nosso código do artigo 2002.
Vamos lá.
Calma que tá chegando.
Os descendentes que concorrerem à
sucessão do ascendente comum.
para os descendentes que concorrerem
à sucessão do ascendente comum são
obrigados para igualar as legítimas, a
conferir, a informar o valor das doações
que dele em vida receberam sob pena de
sonegação, ou seja, perde o direito
àquele valor.
Roberta, tem alguma dispensa de colação?
Tem, tem. Olha aqui, ó. Serão
dispensadas da colação, ou seja, eu não
vou precisar colacionar
o do quando as doações forem
determinadas que tenham saído da parte
disponível. Então, por exemplo, o pai
que doou o imóvel pro filho, no ato de
doação, no ato de liberalidade, ele fala
assim: "Gente,
esse valor saiu da parte disponível,
porque a parte disponível eu não posso
fazer o que eu quiser." Então, ele
dispõe que saiu da parte disponível
expressamente,
contanto que não excedam computado o seu
valor ao tempo da doação, aquele valor
que ele podia dispor, que era de quanto?
50%.
Presume-se imputada na parte disponível
a liberalidade feita a descendente, que
ao tempo do ato não seria chamado a
sucessão na qualidade de herdeiro. Isso
aqui já caiu. Então, se o vô faz uma
doação pro neto e ao tempo daquela
doação não era o neto que receberia a
herança, seria o pai dele, os filhos do
morto e não os netos, ele também não
precisa colacionar, tá dispensado da
colação. Então, muito cuidado. Ele tem
que colacionar, informar o valor para
fins de abatimento, mas o artigo 2005
ele fala da dispensa
da
da colação,
tá? Ele fala da dispensa da colação e eu
vou deixar aqui justamente para evitar
que você esqueça. Então a gente tem a
possibilidade de dispensa
da colação. Tudo bem? Beleza? E essa
dispensa, ela pode constar no próprio
testamento, no próprio título da
liberalidade, ela pode constar na
própria escritura. Então pode acontecer
ali eh a a
dispensa da colação, certo? E esse foi o
nosso encontro de sucessões.
Maravigold, maravigolde. Líndio, Líndio.
Espero que você tenha gostado. Nós
teremos o nosso próximo encontro que é
Direito das Famílias, que salva o melhor
juízo, será dia 16.
Hoje é 14, 15, 16 às 10 horas da manhã.
Entra lá no meu Instagram @roakeiroz.
Eu vou postar todos os dias de todos os
encontros
para que você não perca nenhum. Ai
professora, tô perdido, preciso de uma
complementação. Aqui no nosso canal do
grão AB tem tudo, mas no meu canal
também, Direito como nunca se viu,
também tem um monte de encontro lá. Eu
quero te ajudar a ser aprovado,
aprovada. E eu espero você
ai na OAB para receber a sua carteira em
breve, tá? Vamos dar o print categoria
em todas as telas. Vamos, vamos, vamos.
Então, hoje foi o nosso encontro de
sucessões. Olha que maravilha. nosso
encontro de sucessões. Dá o print nessa
tela,
nessa daí que a gente fala da morte
e todo o nosso curso de direito civil é
todo desenhado, todo lindo para você,
tá?
Dá o print,
vai dando print aí.
A gente falou muita coisa da sucessão,
muita coisa mesmo, hein?
Não esqueça, não esqueça. Tio e sobrinho
são de terceiro grau, mas eles não
concorrem entre si, tá?
Direito real de habitação
e o dever de colação. Tá bom? E é sobre.
Beijo, beijo para você. Até a próxima.
Continue estudando, continue ligado. Vai
dar tudo certo. Eu tenho certeza, eu
sempre digo, somente terá direito à
vista mais fantástica aquele que
suportar o processo de escalada da
montanha, tribo da periferia, música,
resiliência. A escalada é difícil, é
árduo, é solitária. Às vezes bate uma
desesperança muito grande, mas a gente
não tem outra opção senão seguir em
frente. Siga em frente e em frente. A
vida tá aí para ser vivida, apesar de.
Tá bom? Beijo para vocês. Até a próxima.
Ciao. Ciao. [música]